right so we have just received a
statement which buckingham palace says
issued on behalf of her majesty the
queen
the statement says the whole family is
saddened to learn the full extent how
challenging the last few years have been
for harry
and megan the issues raised particularly
that of race
are concerning while some recollections
may vary they are taken
very seriously and will be addressed by
the fami
family privately it goes on to say that
harry
megan and archie will always be
much-loved family members now i'm also
being told
as some background to all of this that
at the heart of this
actually is a family and i think as a
as the media we're being asked to give
the family some time to
discuss all of those issues that have
been raised privately
um i think it's also understood to be
very important for the family to be able
to take time
to consider any response um very
carefully and i think
the sense that i'm getting is that
releasing something today has meant that
that viewers
in the uk actually had the opportunity
last night to be able to
watch the interview for themselves and
to
in some ways figure out exactly how they
felt towards that interview
um it's also being highlighted to me
that it is those issues that were at the
center of that
interview that the royal family are very
much mulling over now
and focusing on uh in a concerted way
with diversity equality
inclusion and mental health have been
really important issues for members of
the royal family and i think for them
there is a sense
of sadness and disappointment when it
comes to
the claims that harry and megan were
making when it was being suggested that
race and racism may have had something
to do with the ways that
megan felt she was being treated the way
that harry felt that
um stories written about megan weren't
being taken seriously
enough and also i think what the palace
are also very keen to highlight
is that those issues of diversity mental
health
inclusion and equality have been issues
that the royal family
for a number of years now have been
focusing on when it comes to
their important charity work when it
comes to the cornerstones really
of what they do publicly when it comes
to carrying out um
their royal duties so i think it is
worth us just recapping
on the official statement that we have
had which has been issued on behalf of
her majesty the queen
in which she has said that the whole
family is saddened to learn the full
extent of how
challenging the last few years have been
for harry and megan
it goes on to say that the issues raised
particularly that of race
are concerning while some recollections
may vary they're taken very seriously
and will be addressed by the family
privately and she also says that harry
megan
and archie will always be much-loved
family
members so there we have it the fact the
palace finally
uh officially commenting on that issue
on that interview that we saw from harry
and megan
and while it may have taken them some
time i think they wanted to make sure
that yeah they put across again that
message that harry and megan
while they may have spoken out well they
may have been critical uh they are still
very much loved members of the family
yeah and uh i mean rihanna a relatively
low key say they want to clearly take
the heat out of this
or so it would seem but the statement
does say
some recollections may vary so
i guess that you know they may be
challenging some of the claims made
in that interview
the word recollection i think does
suggest that
but i think actually all along ever
since we knew that harry and megan were
going to do this interview with oprah
what i've been hearing from those within
the palace was
look we don't want to get into the point
scoring around this we don't want it to
become
a real tit-for-tat battle them saying
one thing us responding with another and
of course that would very much tally
with how
mems the royal family have responded to
personal crises
over the years generally that they don't
want to
unnecessarily put statements out there
and fuel the fire and fuel the kind of
media speculation but i think with this
one at the center of that interview with
two very
toxic subjects um both for the uk widely
but for a very important institution
that is
at the center of the uk institution
and so i think it was inevitable that
they were going to have to say something
i think
when you look at that statement they are
i think very much trying to stick to
this
look we're a family this is the family
line we want to try and deal with this
privately
um but yeah you get the sense that
behind the scenes there are going to be
some
quite difficult discussions i suspect
and while yeah they talk about
recollections may vary they do say that
it is being taken very seriously what
harry and megan have to say but also i
think
and as we saw today with the prince of
wales out and about at a pop-up
vaccination center
um surrounded by people who were from
the black and ethnic
minority communities and him speaking at
that event saying look i
really want to show my support and say
how proud we all are
um to show the work that's been going on
within those communities to encourage
people to go forward to have the
vaccination and i think that's what the
royal family will be hoping is that
actions speak louder than words in in
some ways that they will continue to
push forward when it comes to those
issues related to
diversity inclusion equality um
but yeah no doubt very difficult
listening for them when they heard
harry and megan making those suggestions
that racist comments had been made that
megan's issues around mental health
hadn't been taken seriously